LOVE.
WE WILL SEE YOU TOMORROW.
SEAN HANNITY TAKES OVER.
>> Sean: GOOD SHOW, THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
AS YOU KNOW EVERY NIGHT WOULD
BEGIN, THIS IS A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY THAT OUR COUNTRY IS
GOING TO COME IT CONTINUES.
WE START WITH FACTS WITHOUT
FEARS.
JUST THE FACTS, THE GOOD THE BAD
AND THE UGLY, WHAT SHOULD MOST
CONCERN YOU AND YOUR FAMILY.
SADLY THIS TIME, WE SEE THE
WORSE AND SOME PEOPLE BUT THE
MAJORITY WE SEE THE BEST IN.
WE ARE GOING TO NAME NAMES,
AMERICA NEEDS TO KNOW.
WE START TONIGHT WITH AN
IMPORTANT MESSAGE FROM THE
PRESIDENT EARLIER TODAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I WANT EVERY AMERICAN TO BE
PREPARED FOR THE HARD DAYS THAT
LIE AHEAD.
WE ARE GOING TO GO THROUGH A
VERY TOUGH TWO WEEKS.
AND THEN HOPEFULLY AS THE
EXPERTS ARE PREDICTING, AS I
THINK A LOT OF US ARE
PREDICTING, AFTER HAVING STUDIED
IT SO HARD, WE ARE GOING TO
START SEEING SOME REAL LIGHT AT
THE END OF THE TUNNEL.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A VERY
PAINFUL, VERY, VERY PAINFUL TWO
WEEKS.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT SAYING
THAT WE ALL NEED TO FACE THE
TRUTH, MAKE NO MISTAKE.
THE NEXT TWO WEEKS, MAYBE
LONGER, WILL BE ROUGH.
HERE IS WHERE WE ARE WE ARE
UP-TO-THE-MINUTE TONIGHT.
FEMA HAS SUPPLY 250 AMBULANCES
AND 500 EMTs TO NEW YORK.
THAT’S THE POINT OF INTEREST
RIGHT NOW.
IT COULD SPREAD ELSEWHERE.
THE ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS ARE
DEVELOPING A FACILITIES TO
EXPAND HOSPITAL CAPACITY IN
CALIFORNIA, INCLUDING HUNDREDS
OF ADDITIONAL SITES ACROSS THE
U.S.
FEMA IS SOON DELIVERING A 250
BED FIELD HOSPITAL IN THE STATE
OF MICHIGAN.
AND ADDITIONAL FIELD HOSPITALS
NOW BEING BUILT IN LOUISIANA.
UP TO 500 BEDS AS OF NOW.
AND A 3,000 BED ALTERNATE CARE
SITE, THEY ARE BUILDING THAT IN
NEW ORLEANS.
ALSO FEMA IS ALSO PROVIDING 100
TRAVEL TRAILERS TO HELP WITH
HOUSING NEEDS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION, THEY ARE GIVING
HOSPITALS THE FLEXIBILITY TO USE
NEW FACILITIES FOR NONEFFECTIVE
PEOPLE IF THAT IS IN THEIR BEST
INTEREST.
THEY ARE ON THE GROUND.
THEY NEED TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS.
SO FAR, THIS COUNTRY HAS
COMPLETED 1.1 MILLION TESTS.
THAT’S MORE THAN ANYWHERE ELSE
IN THE WORLD BY FAR.
BUT THAT’S NOT ALL.
TODAY WE GOT MORE FACTS WITHOUT
FEAR FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP ABOUT
AMERICA’S SUPPLIES FOR EXAMPLE
WE’VE HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT
VENTILATORS.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE HAVE ALMOST 10,000
VENTILATORS THAT WE HAVE READY
TOO.
WE HAVE TO HOLD THEM BACK
BECAUSE THE SURGE IS COMING AND
IT’S COMING PRETTY STRONG.
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
IMMEDIATELY MOVE IT INTO PLACE
WITHOUT GOING INTO TAKING IT.
WE SENT A LARGE NUMBER OF
VENTILATORS TO MICHIGAN.
WE ARE SENDING THEM TO
LOUISIANA.
WE SENT ADDITIONAL VENTILATORS
TO NEW YORK.
ADDITIONAL VENTILATORS TO
NEW JERSEY.
>> Sean: KEEP IN MIND MULTIPLE
MAJOR U.S. COMPANIES ARE NOW
MASS-PRODUCING NEW VENTILATORS.
BETWEEN FORD, 3M,
GENERAL MOTORS, OVER 10,000
ADDITIONAL VENTILATORS WILL BE
READY BY MID-APRIL.
THAT’S COMING UP.
15 DAYS.
WITH THOUSANDS TO FOLLOW.
AS MUCH AS 50,000 THEREAFTER.
TONIGHT THERE ARE SO MANY GREAT
BUSINESSES.
WE DO HAVE TO STOP.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE GONE TO BAT
FOR WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY DESERVE OUR PRAISE TONIGHT.
MORE IMPORTANTLY WE OWE A DEBT
OF GRATITUDE TO ALL THE
AMERICANS IN EVERY CORNER OF
THIS COUNTRY RISING TO THE
OCCASION.
STARTING WITH OH, OUR MILITARY
MEN AND WOMEN THAT ARE NOT
HELPING.
AMAZING AMERICANS.
NATIONAL GUARD.
THIS IS THE BEST OUR COUNTRY HAS
TO OFFER.
WE CAN SEE THIS IN THE ROUGHEST
OF TIMES.
EARLIER TODAY THE PRESIDENT
SALUTED THE BRAVE DOCTORS AND
SCIENTISTS AND NURSES AND ALL
THE HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS,
THEY’LL PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE
LINE.
THEY DO IT AROUND THE CLOCK,
AROUND THE COUNTRY TIRELESSLY
WORKING FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
ON THE FRONT LINES TO BEAT BACK
THIS WELL, IN REASONABLE INVISIB
>> I WATCHED THE DOCTORS AND
NURSES WALKING INTO THAT
HOSPITAL THIS MORNING.
IT’S LIKE MILITARY PEOPLE GOING
INTO BATTLE, GOING INTO WAR.
THE BRAVERY IS INCREDIBLE.
AND I JUST HAVE TO TAKE MY HAT.
I WOULD TAKE MY HAT IF I WERE
WEARING A HAT, I WOULD RIP THAT
HAT OFF SO FAST AND I WOULD SAY
YOU PEOPLE ARE JUST INCREDIBLE.
THEY REALLY ARE.
THEY ARE VERY BRAVE.
>> Sean: THESE MEDICAL
WORKERS, THEY HAVE A TOUGH ROAD
AHEAD, ALL PRAISE TO THEM
TONIGHT.
BY THE WAY, THIS BRINGS US TO
OUR FACTS WITHOUT FEAR.
THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT WE’VE
GOT TO KEEP AN EYE ON AS A
COUNTRY.
WE ALL NEED TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
WORRY, PANIC, HYSTERIA, THAT’S
NOT THE ANSWER.
WE HAVE TO THINK STRATEGICALLY
AND STAND BACK AND MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS WE CAN MAKE BASED ON
NEW INFORMATION INVOLVING
EVERYDAY.
HOSPITALS ARE ON THE COUNTRY,
THEY ARE NOW BEING STRETCHED
DANGEROUSLY THIN.
PROTECTIVE MEDICAL SUPPLIES, WE
ARE GETTING REPORTS ARE RUNNING
LOW IN THE AREAS, ONE BIG
CONCERN IS MORE PEOPLE, YOUNGER
PEOPLE ARE BEING IMPACTED.
REMEMBER, EVERY SINGLE EXPERT
FOR PRETTY MUCH FIVE, SIX WEEKS
SAID AND REPORTED JUST THE VERY
OPPOSITE.
ONLY OLDER PEOPLE WITH
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS OR
COMPROMISED IMMUNE SYSTEMS.
NOW, IF THE PATTERNS THAT WE SEE
AND HAVE WITNESSED AROUND THE
WORLD HOLD IN THE UNITED STATES,
A NEW CORONA CASES WILL SHARPLY
ARISES PARTIALLY BECAUSE WE ARE
DOING MORE TESTING THAN ANYBODY
ELSE.
REMEMBER THERE ARE PEOPLE
ASYMPTOMATIC SO PEOPLE WILL NOT
EVEN KNOW THEY HAVE THIS VIRUS.
THE DEATH TOLL WILL LEG BEHIND,
BUT IS DR. FAUCI AND OTHERS SAID
INCREASE BEFORE WE SEE THE VIRUS
LEVEL OFF AND ULTIMATELY WHAT WE
ALL WANT, TO DECREASE AND I’LL
GET BACK TO THE LIVES WE WANT TO
LIVE.
THE WHITE HOUSE NOW PREDICTING
IT’S POSSIBLE BETWEEN 100,000
AND 200,000 DEATHS IN THE U.S.
BUT IT COULD HAVE BEEN
2.2 MILLION.
VERY INTERESTING CHARTS.
LET US HOPE FOR THE BEST-CASE
SCENARIO.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DR. FAUCI, SHOULD AMERICANS
BE PREPARED FOR THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT THEY WILL BE 100,000
AMERICANS WHO DIE FROM THIS
VIRUS?
>> THE ANSWER IS YES.
AS SOBERING A NUMBER AS THAT IS,
WE SHOULD BE PREPARED FOR IT.
IS IT GOING TO BE THAT MUCH?
I HOPE NOT, AND I THINK THE MORE
WE PUSH ON THE MITIGATION, THE
LESS LIKELIHOOD IT WOULD BE THAT
NUMBER.
BUT AS BEING REALISTIC, WE NEED
TO PREPARE OURSELVES THAT THAT
IS THE POSSIBILITY.
>> Sean: THIS IS WHY THE
PRESIDENT EXTENDED THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING PLAN UNTIL APRIL 30.
ALL MEDICAL EXPERTS ARE SAYING
THAT WILL PREVENT PEOPLE FROM
CONTRACTING THE VIRUS, AND
EXPONENTIALLY THAT WILL
MATHEMATICALLY PREVENT PEOPLE
FROM ULTIMATELY DYING.
WE WANT TO SAVE AMERICAN LIVES.
WE BELIEVE IN LIFE.
WE PROTECT THE LIVES OF PEOPLE
ALL ACROSS THIS GLOBE.
WE’VE GOT TO PROTECT AMERICANS
NOW.
ALL HANDS ON DECK.
NOW IT IS A CONCERNING NUMBER,
FRANKLY DOWNRIGHT SCARY.
WE HOPE AND PRAY THAT WE NEVER
GET THERE.
AND THAT LIVES ARE SAVED.
DR. FAUCI TALKED ABOUT IT.
THAT COULD ALL HAPPEN TOO APPEAR
BECAUSE OF THE PRESIDENT’S
DECISIVE ACTIONS, WE HAVE TIME
TO POTENTIALLY CURB THAT NUMBER
AND MITIGATE THIS DISEASE.
TRAVEL BAN, THAT BROUGHT US A
TONE OF TIME.
THE QUARANTINES, ALSO BOUGHT US
TIME.
OUR CURRENT.
MACRO SOCIAL DISTANCING IS
BUYING US MORE TIME.
NOW THE THING IS, NO PRESIDENT
HAS DONE MORE COMPACT AND MORE
QUICKLY.
THE BOOK ON PANDEMICS HAS NOW
BEEN REWRITTEN.
FUTURE GENERATIONS WILL LEARN
FROM THE LESSONS OF THIS
PANDEMIC.
NEVER BEFORE HAVE ALL OF THESE
NEW THINGS HAPPENED.
NOW HOSPITALS AND DOCTORS AND
AMERICAN BUSINESSES, THEY HAVE
TIME TO FIGHT BACK, AS THEY HAVE
BEEN.
LOOK AT THE ANNOUNCEMENT THIS
WEEK.
ABBOTT LABS CREATING A
FIVE-MINUTE TEST.
THAT WILL BE A GAME CHANGER.
STUDIES NOW UNDERWAY TO
DETERMINE THE EFFECTS OF NEW
TREATMENT AND A VACCINE IS
ALREADY IN PHASE ONE TRIALS.
IT USED TO TAKE YEARS TO GET THE
SEQUENCE OF A VIRUS.
AMERICAN INGENUITY, BRILLIANT
SCIENTISTS, MEDICAL RESEARCHERS
AND DOCTORS, INCREDIBLE PEOPLE
ALL OF THEM.
MEANWHILE ALSO AMERICAN
BUSINESSES HAVE STARTED
MASS-PRODUCING PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT.
WHEREVER THE NEED IS, THAT OUR
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS, THAT
THEY DESPERATELY NEED AND WE
MUST PROVIDE FOR THEM.
AND N95 RESPIRATORS, MASKS,
GLOVES, SHIELDS, PROTECTIVE
SUITS ARE NOW BEING MADE BY
COMPANIES ALL ACROSS AMERICA.
THIS GREAT AMERICAN INGENUITY
AND HARD WORK IS PART OF THE
FACTS THAT SHOULD GIVE YOU HOPE
TONIGHT.
TONIGHT WE HAVE OTHER GOOD NEWS
TO SHARE.
WE WILL START IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE AFTER TWO WEEKS OF STRICT
SOCIAL DISTANCING POLICIES,
DOCTORS ARE NOW CAUTIOUSLY
OPTIMISTIC THAT THAT CURB IS NOW
FLATTENING OUT AROUND THE
BAY AREA.
ACCORDING TO POLITICO, HOSPITALS
ARE REPORTING FEWER CASES THAN
THEY EXPECTED TO SEE.
THAT IS GOOD, AS WE LOOK AT THIS
NOW, THE SCARY TIME WE ARE
HEADING INTO.
NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY,
CONNECTICUT AND MAYBE SOME OTHER
HOT SPOTS AROUND THE COUNTRY.
LAST WEEK, WASHINGTON STATE,
THEY SAW A DECREASE IN THE PACE
OF NEW CASES, PARTICULARLY
AROUND SEATTLE.
A LOT OF GOOD WORK BY THE
GOVERNOR OUT THERE.
MEANWHILE IN ITALY, EUROPE’S
CORONAVIRUS APPY, NEW CASES
FINALLY OF THE VIRUS HAVE BEGUN
THE PROCESS WE HOPE OF
LEVELING OFF AND WE ARE NOW AT A
TWO WEEK LOW.
ACCORDING TO A BRAND-NEW STUDY
FROM A MEDICAL JOURNAL IN THE
UNITED KINGDOM, THE DEATH RATE,
THEY SAY FOR COVID-19, THOSE
CASES COULD BE AS LOW AS 0.6%.
LET ME BE CLEAR.
WE ARE NOW IN AN UNCERTAIN TIME,
BUT WHAT IS CERTAIN IS THE
MIGHT, THEY WILL, THE POWER, THE
INGENUITY OF YOU, WE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SOON THIS INVISIBLE ENEMY, IT
WILL BE DEFEATED.
BUT HANG ON TIGHT.
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS WILL
DEFINITELY BE ROCKY.
THAT’S ESPECIALLY TRUE IN THE
STATE OF NEW YORK WHERE WE ARE
TONIGHT.
WHICH IS NOW THE EPICENTER AT
THIS MOMENT OF THE DISEASE.
TODAY THE STATE RELEASED A
STATEMENT, ONCE AGAIN BLAMING
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THEY RELEASED A STATEMENT.
THE STATES WERE NOT SLOW TO
RESPOND.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS
ABSENT."
OKAY.
ANDREW CUOMO, YOU ARE MISSING IN
ACTION.
MAYOR de BLASIO, YOU ARE
MISSING IN ACTION.
REALLY?
YOU HAVE THE HIGHEST PER CAPITA
TAXES IN THE COUNTRY, NEW YORK
STATE AND CITY.
AND VIRTUALLY ZERO STOCKPILE OF
EQUIPMENT, MASKS, GLOVES.
NOTHING.
THE STOCKPILE OF VENTILATORS,
TOTALLY INSUFFICIENT.
AND THE STATES HAVE FEWER
VENTILATORS ON HAND THAN THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE.
IN FACT, FORMER LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK BETSY
McCOY POINTS OUT THAT CUOMO
WAS WARNED OF THE SHORTAGE
OF VENTILATORS IN 2015.
THEY ONLY HAD 2,000.
THE TASK FORCE RECOMMENDED THEY
NEEDED 18,000.
SO INSTEAD OF BUYING 16,000
MORE, CUOMO DID NOTHING.
AND NOW HE IS SCREAMING AT THE
PRESIDENT WHOSE BUILDING
HOSPITAL AFTER HOSPITAL, SENDING
ALL THE VENTILATORS AND HE PUTS
IN THE WAREHOUSE, NOW HE’S
LECTURING THE PRESIDENT, WELL,
THAT’S WHY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SENT OVER 4,000 TO
YOU THAT YOU STUCK IN A
WAREHOUSE.
MULTIPLE EMERGENCY HOSPITALS.
YOU KNOW HOW THE U.S. NS
COMFORTER IN NEW YORK HARBOR AND
IT GETS EVEN WORSE.
CUOMO BORROWING NEW YORK
CITIZENS, THIS HAS GOT TO END.
HOSPITALIZED -- IF YOU’RE NOT
HOSPITALIZED, THE LAST PLACE YOU
WANT TO BE IS IN A HOSPITAL
RIGHT NOW IF YOU CAN PREVENTED.
NOW THE ONLY PLACE YOU CAN GO IN
THE STATE OF NEW YORK TO GET
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE IS AT A
PHARMACY.
THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO GIVE IT
TO YOU.
THAT’S RIGHT.
GOVERNOR CUOMO RESCINDED THAT
ORDER AND TAKE RESPONSIBILITY,
WHY DIDN’T YOU BUY THOSE
VENTILATORS?
HE SPENT $750 MILLION ON A
FAILED SOLAR PANEL PROJECT IN
UPSTATE NEW YORK.
IT WENT BELLY UP.
WHY DIDN’T YOU SPEND MONEY ON
DOWNS?
REALLY?
YOU’RE GOING TO ATTACK THE
PRESIDENT OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
EMERGENCY?
YOU ALSO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
YOUR POOR PLANNING.
NEW YORK IS THE NUMBER-ONE
TERROR TARGET AND THE ENTIRE
WORLD.
NEW YORK SHOULD BE PREPARED.
THE FIRST TRADE CENTER ATTACK,
9/11, NEW YORK, HIGHEST
CONCENTRATION OF 10 BILLION
PEOPLE, SMALLEST
GEOGRAPHICAL LOCATION.
AND A PANDEMIC, NEW YORK CITY IS